le territoire est sous la menace de
l'impact direct d'un cyclone dans 24 à
36 heures
la martinique est en vigilance orange
soyez très vigilants préparez vous tenez
vous informés de l'évolution du
phénomène en consultant régulièrement
les bulletins de météo france est
appliqué les consignes des autorités
préparez votre habitation protection des
ouvertures mise à l'abri des objets
démontage des installations susceptibles
d'être emportés météores dos les objets
susceptibles d'être touchés par une
inondation le cas échéant protéger vos
embarcation nautique par une mise à
terre ou une mise à l'abri
organisez votre stockage de nourriture
et matériel divers attention denrées
périssables stockées dans votre
congélateur pertes en cas de coupure
prolongée de l'électricité protégez vos
documents personnels est important
restez à l écoute et restez connectés
sur martinique la première